in the age of social media when the
public can easily be manipulated mislead
can we be sure that the people know best
should we constrain democracy in hand
ever more authority to experts or do we
need more direct democracy for our
representatives to be the messengers of
the people well to discuss all these
important issues I'm joined by Angela
Eagle former shadow Secretary of State
for Business Innovation and Skills
Phillip blonde is a political theorist
theologian and director of the Res
Publica think-tank Carl Miller whose
research director of the demos Center
for the analysis of social media he
recently published death of the gods the
new global power grab so let's get going
Angela should we expand democracy or
give more power to experts well I've
spent 26 years in Parliament 40 years as
a member of one of our major political
parties the Labour Party in case anyone
was wondering and so I like to think
I've been a sort of practitioner on the
front line of trying to make democracy
work and I think that democracy is the
best form of government it's not perfect
but when you look at all of the other
options for running a country with
legitimacy I think that democracy comes
top and so what we have to do is look at
how we can improve the meaning of how
democracy works the participation that
people have how we can ensure that we
reform some of our democratic
institutions and by that I mean also
Parliament how we can devolve power to
the regions local government down closer
to where decisions ought to be made and
how we can ensure that we get away from
a sort of utilitarian passive view of
democracy so our elections look more
like a choice of brands in a supermarket
and that democracy is somehow a passive
thing to having a much more active
democracy where the decisions that you
make actually make a real difference
and I think the interesting thing about
the last election was how that debate
began to happen in a much more
meaningful way than we've seen in the
last few years so I would say yes
democracy is in crisis I have never
lived through an era where it's more
question than it is now where levels of
cynicism are so high where the capacity
to generate fake news and propaganda is
so turbocharged where the types of
debate that we have in our democratic
discourse are so trivial and meaningless
so we've got a lot of work to do but I
actually think rule by the people for
the people expressed in democratic votes
it's the only way that you can
legitimize government making decisions
on behalf of the people that they're
there to represent thank you very much
Phillip should we expand democracy or
give more power to experts so let me
explain why that I I understand Angela's
belief and in certain ways I support it
but I think that's very strong clear and
compelling evidence against it first of
all lots of things are more legitimate
than democracy in this country for
instance the monarchy it's much more
popular there as an institution than
Parliament then various political
figures as our parents and the idea that
political legitimacy only can derive
from democracy especially when democracy
really is only post Second World War as
a mass phenomenon in the way we
articulate it is that is I think
demonstrably wrong I also think
democracy as we have practiced it aka Bo
nobler
bush that rhymed that's a good sign has
failed as the means of securing justice
inequity if you look at the levels of
inequality that we've created if you
look at the levels of monopolization
democracy and governance by plutocracy
have become synonymous take our most
unequal modern democracy which would be
the United States which was founded on
the most French form of of democracy
found outside France of you know
destruction of all hierarchies
everything is absolutely level the
levels of inequality they're the levels
of pernicious warfare against the bottom
third of society on both a racial and
non-racial level are cannot be believed
unless you've lived there and
experienced it so there's no necessary
relationship at all between democracy
and equality democracy and equity and
democracy and injustice and it's worth
stating it's a GCSE level point but it
needs repeating in the adult world the
democracy and and goodness are often
opposed the Nuremberg Laws were brought
in by a completely legitimate German
National Socialist government if we have
democracy is the only source of
legitimacy we legitimize any
majoritarian will no matter how brutal
or callous or extreme so so yeah we can
but I'm going to continue another minute
so what I'm going to suggest you is
democracy is in crisis because it's not
working because it's not delivering
justice and that's because people think
justice and democracy are synonymous
were clearly palpably and evidently
they're not and actually what people are
opting for and they've done it in both
Turkey and Russia and Putin would win by
the way an overall majority even we
didn't fix elections which he clearly
does his people think that authoritarian
popular authoritarian
are now more likely to operate against
vested interest and deliverer equality
than democracy and I think they have a
case thank you very much Carl Miller
thanks very much afternoon everyone
Phillips said almost nothing that I
agreed with there but to to I'm gonna
I'm gonna resist jumping in there yet
and actually setting out a kind of
slightly different stall first kind of
my angle if you couldn't guess it from
our job description is technology and
and how digital tech is interacting and
changing politics and the rest of
society and and for a year I I went
around the world trying to understand
this change and trying to understand how
power was changing and what I saw was at
time and time again it wasn't so much
that democracy was was being destroyed
outright it was more that it's kind of
trapped in this kind of long worrying
kind of residual decline into
irrelevance like time and again the
people that I saw they were actually
trying to change the world weren't
trying to do it by trying to win the
argument
they weren't try and do it in the courts
and they weren't trying to do it within
political arena they were simply
building technology to change the world
for them and they essentially saw the
whole of politics with some
legitimization I think as basically
being in a relevant slideshow now I'm
gonna bring one example out to put in
front of you the point of politics
boiled down is to make law enforceable
law which controls the activities which
can and cannot take place within the
polity that that politics controls we
are living through the worst crisis of
law enforcement as just one example in
the history of modern policing half of
crime that happens through the internet
you are twenty times more likely to have
your social media accounts burgled than
your house you're more likely to get a
virus then all forms of violent crime
put together online fraud is by far the
most common crime happening in the in
the world today I went on spent time
with cybercrime police teams across the
country and went on a cybercrime
weighted raid with them and and and
there's only one surprising thing about
the raid that I actually went on not
surprising that this
I'm a criminal existed I'm not
surprising that he was actually the
least hardened criminal I've ever seen
in my life I kind of expected that he
might jump out a window or somehow it
might come down to me to save the day
but he was so shocked to find the police
in his house and that he could barely
talk he could barely stand and that
wasn't surprising because the barrister
entry into cybercrime are unbelievably
low an idiot can do cybercrime I did
some cybercrime I should know
i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i I was using a
ransomware device and you know you know
you've all seen the kind of like trope
or the cyber criminal you know the kind
of genius teenager with the hoodie for
some reason typing binary code into a
green screen in it in a darkened attic
none of which is is really true like you
open up a program and it says hi cold
you want to commit some cyber crime
today and you click a button and it says
how long do you want your ransom words
go on you drop down menu if to two
months and it says how much bitcoins
won't be will pay pay and you type in
the number two it's easier to use a
Microsoft words drop down menu
point-and-click cybercrime an idiot can
do it and then you go to Def Con or soar
in Las Vegas and you see the most
unbelievable feats that hackers that
have certainly risen as being a new
power elite actually do they I saw in
front of my own two eyes people
wrestling controls from laptops not
connect to the internet using lights
using light you couldn't see using sound
using sound you couldn't hear I saw Tom
prove that could cause any wind turbine
in the world to burst into flames
you